good morning Hank it's Tuesday May 3rd
2016 I gotta go vote walk with me just
an absolutely beautiful day for an
election done and done the best part is
you get a sticker you'll never guess
where I'm going next that's right Hank
in a stunning turn of events I find
myself in an airport you know my number
one complaint about the Indianapolis
International Airport which I truly do
believe to be the best Airport on earth
every 12 minutes I mean at what point in
human history is it just presumed that
you can't smoke in an airport I think
that point is in the past on the other
hand I guess if it weren't for that
message I would be pretty happy just to
live the rest of my life in the
Indianapolis International Airport and
maybe that's what they're up to maybe
they're trying to get me to actually get
on a plane today's video comes you in
for very special parts part one voting I
already did that part two Hank today is
also my dad's birthday which I guess
means it's also your dad's birthday lots
of people don't know this but our dad
basically ran our company until a year
ago he did like all the payroll and
budgeting and spreadsheets that made
crash course in scishow possible he's
also just a really great dad and person
happy birthday dad I love you why is it
so easy to say I love you to my parents
when I can only say it once a year to my
brother on Esther day anyway part 3
racing so I'm gonna be driving the pace
car on May 14th at the Angie's List
Grand Prix of Indianapolis I was very
excited about this because I'm a big fan
of Indy cars but then I went to the
track and I tried I did my practice I
thought that being the pace car driver
was like a purely ceremonial position
you know like running with the Olympic
torch or being the prime minister of
putin's russia but it turns out no i
have to drive the car what is for me
very fast like 110 miles an hour in the
straightaway so I'm very scared if you
watch it on TV just remember I'm doing
my best part for speaking of crash and
god I hope I don't crash crash course
Hank here in the United States millions
of high school students are taking their
AP tests right now this is always great
news for crash course our views
skyrocket anyway I just wanted to take
this opportunity to say to high school
students doing well on tests is great
but it is not the point of life or the
point of Education tests are somewhat
inefficient way of measuring your
understanding of like life the universe
and everything but the point is not to
do well on the test the point is to have
a more engaged and fulfilling life
during this year one brief flicker of
consciousness so good luck and study
hard but not just for the test part 5
that's are there only gonna be 4 parts
do I contradict myself very well then I
contradict myself I am large I contain
multitudes right part 5 is my beard hey
cuz you may have notice
I have shaved I didn't shave for six
consecutive weeks because AFC Wimbledon
the fourth tier English soccer team
sponsored by nerdfighteria just kept
winning and it got to the point where I
was pretty desperate to shave but I also
wanted AFC Wimbledon to make the
playoffs because if they made the
playoffs they'd have a 25% chance of
becoming a third tier English soccer
team and it's always been my dream to
sponsor a third tier English soccer team
and then Hank the most amazing thing
happened first AFC Wimbledon lost a game
allowing me to shave and then another
team didn't win a game allowing AFC
Wimbledon to make the playoffs anyway so
put two AFC Wimbledon if they make it to
the finals Hank I am going to Wembley
Stadium to watch the game also vice
sports made a great documentary about
the team in my relationship with them so
check that out part 6 last part I
promised VidCon nerdfighters if you want
to participate I know I can't if you
want to participate in the signings and
meet and greets you have to register by
May 13th so fair warning alright the no
smoking messages have gotten annoying
enough that I'm going to get on the
plane Hank I'll see you on Friday